je m'appelle morgan j'ai 28 ans j'habite
à la verrière et le 2 septembre 2000 22
à 20 heures je vais partir pour 24
heures de marche cette marche c'est pour
la ligue contre le cancer un hommage à
mon papa parti bien cru
[Musique]
mon père il m'a appris un mois d'octobre
2021 qu'il était atteint du cancer de la
vessie on lui a enlevé sa vessie et un
mois et demi après il a il a fait des
malaises il a fini par calcémie s'est
avéré que le cancer s'était propagé au
niveau des eaux et du coup bah il est
décédé de un prix alors le défi c'est de
marché 24 heures à partir de chez moi de
faire tout le tour de paris et de
revenir chez moi
[Musique]
l'antenne de sollicitations et non cia
samedi sommes dit ouais tu contenir vers
quelle heure e je sais pas encore mais
je voulais venir à la base vendredi pour
faire le départ avec toi mais je
pourrais pas mais il viendrait sûrement
samedi dans les coups de 11 heures 11
heures ouais marché deux bonnes heures
avec toi sur instagram il y aura des
live avec certains invités qui sont en
train d'être sélectionné ensuite je
ferai des story et après quelques jours
plus tard il y aura l'intérieur même du
24 heures sur youtube
ma chaîne youtube c'est morgane ito et à
travers cette chaîne j'essaie de mettre
en vidéo tous les défis sportifs que je
me lance la dernière vidéo c'est que en
octobre je me suis inscrit au semi
marathon et l'objectif c'était de
montrer que l'effort physique c'est une
chose mais que tout se passe dans la
tête
ni ravitaillement
km se passe bien je déroule pas fatigué
pour moi ce combat il est important
parce que il ya davantage de cancers
autour de moi et je me rends compte que
c'est ce fléau là il faut le combattre
pour le combattre il faut aller chercher
des dons il faut permettre à la science
de de trouver les moyens pour résoudre
ce problème c'est ça le départ va se
passer avec la présence du maire
monsieur nicolas dainville ainsi que
quelques élus et j'ai lancé un
événement sur facebook public pour les
gens qui veulent s'y rendre ils ont
l'adresse ils ont lieu ils ont l'air
pour donner pour l'association c'est la
ligue contre le cancer qui va créer la
cagnotte et on pourra y participer tout
en cliquant sur le lien et en y ajoutant
un paiement de la somme que vous voulez